tout le monde bouge pas les eagles
n'importe quoi votre premier souvenir
vous souvenez de votre premier souvenir
allons jouer modeste quand j'étais
déguisé en fait à l'école au premier
choc
mon premier choc du début on fait quand
t'es quoi tu t'es vu en fait quand on va
transformer quand j'ai transformé
quelqu'un avec la baguette
parce que s'il ya un petit délai il ya
un filet chacun quand tu dis quelque
chose de temps qu'on traduise est tout
trouvé le chemin retard demain si bien
je me la faire et du dyson gilles giles
il est si bien qu est ce qui vient votre
premier péché ça me choque en souvenez
on est ce que c'était un péché j'ai
coupé les cheveux d'une fille enfin
c'est pas empêché ce que je vous la
trouviez trop joli ça ça pour le reste
ce qu'elle allait appliquer un mec
ah bah oui non ça c'était un pêché ça
sympa je suis carrément un péché s'est
pressée cheveux dites moi votre premier
amour
oui
si la belle sandrine ça lui rappelle
cette chanson ça ça vous rappelle que
premièrement oui et là elle a du mal à
la main ça l'air de rien avec souris est
tout bête pour charlie c'est quelque
chose de très très dur degrés un peu
plus écouté cette chanson très très fort
là elle sourit parce qu'elle est forte
c'est vous qui l'avez argué oui parce
qu'il van hamme largo si on est tombé
sur un os un point d un salarié du nord
et d'europe centrale toutes les deux
d'un point commun elles s'appellent
zénith chèque
oui c'est vrai alors dernier l'un des
deux points communs d'être d'europe
centrale toutes les deux vous êtes des
pays en fait de décommander premier
livre par les dj la nano est chez lui
qui parle la vie tu peux lui demander
les adresses web c'est sa bataille
tariq ramadam première cuite
oui un réveillon de nouvel an il ya
longtemps l'a longtemps way avec ma
soeur premier pétard jamais non pas une
taffe oui comme tu le donnes et ça m'a
fait cracher la fumée voilà arrivé ça
votre première chance dans la vie qui
vous la donner je pense que sans les
parents premier échec c'est quoi le
premier chèque
j'ai à peu
je sais moi je vais pas tout faire mais
sympa et je te regarde la tv
non je dirais n'est résolu parce que
c'est vraiment un film que j'aime pas ah
ouais et la première chose que vous
faites le matin en me réveillant je vais
voir ma fille